Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je viens d’avoir 12 ans.
(Applaudissements)
Et depuis l’âge de quatre ans, je fugue.
Mes parents sont dépassés, débordés.
Ils sont même en colère, parfois,
parce qu’ils n’arrivent pas
à m’en empêcher.
Je suis là avec eux.
Et la minute suivante, pfuit !
je pars avec mes amis
Katniss, Louis, Achille, Ewilan
Mike Horn, Athos, Porthos
et plein d’autres.
Mes fugues sont longues,
dévorantes de vie,
débordantes d’émotions,
pleines de connaissances et d’aventures.
Mais surtout, mes fugues sont littéraires.
En gros, je fugue, en restant chez moi,
discret et caché, un livre dans la main
et des personnages de roman
comme compagnons de route.
Les livres enchantent ma vie.
Mon plus beau souvenir :
quand on ne m’a pas interrompu,
et que pour la première fois,
j’ai pu lire un livre entier
sans avoir à sortir de ma bulle.
C’était « La République abîmée »
de Patrice Duhamel et Jacques Santamaria.
(Rires)
Je me suis enfilé d’une traite
l’affaire Marković,
la tuerie d’Auriol, l’affaire Arendal,
l’affaire Ben Barka et toutes les autres.
Et franchement, ne pas être interrompu
une seule fois, c’était magique.
Le moment où mon cœur
s’est follement emballé,
quand, en allant emprunter
des livres à l’université,
je suis tombé
sur les vingt tomes de la série
des « Rougon-Macquart » d’Émile Zola.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Moi qui avais adoré
« Au bonheur des dames ».
La plus grosse déception de ma vie,
je la dois à Robert Sabatier.
Quand David part en Amérique
et qu’Olivier reste à Paris
alors qu’ils avaient tissé
des liens d’amitié très forts.
Non, mais quel gâchis.
Enfin, voilà, vous l’aurez compris,
j’aime la lecture au-delà de tout.
Les mots, les phrases,
un style, un rythme.
Autant de manettes qui actionnent
mes émotions et stimulent mon imagination.
D’après les critères
du Centre national du livre
dont une étude porte sur les Français,
je suis un gros lecteur.
(Rires)
Car je lis plus de vingt livres par an.
En réalité, je lis entre 200
et 300 livres par an,
des livres qui font entre cent
et plus de mille pages,
ce qui signifie que je lis très
approximativement 100 000 pages par an.
(Rires)
Comme 96 % des jeunes Français
de 7 à 19 ans en 2020,
je lis.
68% lisent au moins une fois par semaine.
Les statistiques le prouvent, la lecture
n’est pas un fait rare chez les jeunes.
Et pourtant,
auprès des jeunes, si on est beaucoup,
on peut passer
pour un intello ou un ringard.
Par contre, auprès des adultes,
si un enfant lit beaucoup :
« Bravo, il est intelligent ! »
(Rires)
« Et ça le mènera loin. »
Le résultat, c'est une sorte
d'incompréhension générationnelle.
Les parents demandent
à leurs ados d’être des ringards
(Rires)
et donc de saboter
leur popularité au collège.
Tout ça pour leur bien.
Quoi qu’il en soit, c’est dommage
que l’on fasse de la lecture
un outil du bon élève,
un indicateur de son niveau de sérieux.
Plutôt que de le considérer
comme une passion à développer
ou pas.
Ah oui, un autre truc qui me fait sourire.
J’ai remarqué que l’adulte,
persuadé que l’expérience lui permettait
de définir une lecture pour chaque âge,
une norme, se considérait à même,
par exemple, de décréter que lire,
comprendre et apprécier
« Sur les épaules de Darwin »
de Jean-Claude Ameisen,
à 12 ans, c’est impossible.
Eh bien si, j’adore Jean-Claude Ameisen
et depuis plusieurs années en plus.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je n’ai jamais entendu
ses émissions sur France Inter,
mais ses livres,
waouh !
C’est de la science littéraire qui n’a pas
besoin de simplifier les informations
pour qu’elles soient comprises.
Il se contente de raconter, par exemple,
comme s’il s’agissait
de petites histoires,
comment les chauffeurs de taxi londoniens
ont développé leur hippocampe,
c’est-à-dire la partie du cerveau
qui joue un rôle primordial
dans la navigation spatiale,
juste en mémorisant
l’enchevêtrement des rues londoniennes.
Ou comment les fourmis suivent toujours
les phéromones les plus récentes
pour aller à un endroit donné.
Et tout ça, c'est simple, poétique,
documenté et vrai.
Quand je suis dans un magasin,
un livre à la main,
(Rires)
il y a souvent des adultes
pleins de bonnes intentions
qui viennent me dire
que mes parents doivent être fiers de moi.
J’ai ainsi pu constater
que ma pratique addictive est félicitée
en raison de sa nature même.
Mais même si elle a généralement toutes
les faveurs de la plupart des adultes,
pour mes parents, je lis trop, je lis
des choses que je ne devrais pas lire
et le temps que me prend
la lecture leur pose problème.
Ils ont peur que ça me coupe du monde.
Cela a commencé très tôt.
Quand j’étais petit,
c’était comme un réveil intégré
par mon horloge biologique qui disait :
« 23 heures. C’est le moment. »
Mes parents vont au lit,
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
et moi, tout endormi, voilà que
tout à coup, mes yeux papillonnent,
mes mains cherchent à tâtons mes lunettes.
Et c’est parti pour le rituel de la nuit :
lire un livre sous la couette.
Trop bien !
(Rires)
Bon, après, j’étais complètement
épuisé le lendemain
et difficile de camoufler la trace
des lunettes écrasées contre ma joue,
les branches tordues par l’appui,
et la trace de salive sur le livre
qui forcément finissait
par me servir d’oreiller.
Alors, évidemment, suite à ces épisodes
répétitifs et à leurs conséquences :
mon manque de concentration à l’école,
mon envie impondérée de lire
en cours au lieu de travailler,
mes justifications mensongères
et mes ruses pour pouvoir lire
toujours et toujours plus,
l’adulte a décidé qu’il devait y avoir
répression contre la rébellion.
(Rires)
Je me suis pas mal défendu,
mais au final :
lunettes confisquées la nuit.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Livres confisqués la nuit
et parfois la journée
et une série de règles anti-lecture.
« Pas de livres au restaurant,
c’est malpoli.
Pas de livres dans la voiture,
tu vas être malade. »
C’est faux !
Je n’ai jamais été malade en voiture !
Pas de livres après 20 heures,
pas de livres avant 6 heures,
et pas plus de huit heures de lecture
dans tout le week-end.
Et j'en passe.
Une vraie dictature.
(Rires)
La lecture est devenue
un sujet de conflit dans ma famille.
Exactement comme dans
de nombreuses familles
où les parents jugent que la tablette
devrait être remplacée par les livres.
(Rires)
Dans la voiture, par exemple,
privé de livres,
je restais un fugueur littéraire.
Je me récitais des passages
que j’avais particulièrement appréciés
de certaines lectures
et que j’avais fini par retenir par cœur.
Je me souviens qu’une fois
assis à l’arrière,
j’avais récité un de ces passages
à ma mère
pour partager avec elle
ce moment de bonheur.
Elle s’était alors offusquée :
« Quoi ? Tu as pris un livre
dans la voiture
alors que je te l’avais interdit ? »
On s’était finalement garé sur le côté
pour vérifier qu’il n’y avait
vraiment pas eu infraction.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Enfin, voilà où en était la situation,
pour moi, il y a un an.
Trop de règles, de restrictions,
donc des parents épuisés
et moi en manque de lecture.
J’ai réfléchi à ce qui pourrait soulager
tout le monde
et j’ai décidé de mettre
au point un plan de restructuration.
(Rires)
Pas mal, le mot.
Je l’ai trouvé dans des revues d’actualité
sur les conséquences économiques
de la Covid.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Voici mon plan.
Opposé au dos de mes parents, concernant
ma capacité à m’intégrer au monde réel,
un projet bien ficelé.
Au passage, merci à mon frère
et à ma sœur
pour l’idée et la campagne de propagande
auprès de mes parents.
(Rires)
Et franchement, je n’ai pas
payé cher leurs services.
Non, non, c’était une blague,
je n’ai absolument rien payé.
La confiscation de mes lunettes,
le racket de ma fratrie,
les méthodes dictatoriales
que j’aie subies,
je vais finir par avoir
les services sociaux qui vont débarquer !
Même pas sûr qu’ils me trouvent
une famille d’accueil avec des bouquins.
(Rires)
OK, on va éviter.
Oubliez ce que je viens de vous dire.
Donc, mon super projet,
c’était d’ouvrir une chaine YouTube
« La croisée des livres »
où lors de courts montages audiovisuels,
je présenterai mes lectures
en les mettant en lien.
J’interviewerai des auteurs
et des lecteurs.
Je me lancerai ainsi dans le montage,
la promotion de ma chaîne
et la communication
avec d’autres passionnés.
Bingo !
Projet accepté par
mes adultes responsables.
(Rires)
A partir de là, j’ai pu justifier
mes lectures et mes relectures.
Ma chaine m’a même permis
plein de rencontres réelles,
vraiment fantastiques.
J’ai maintenant 562 abonnés
que j’appelle des voyageurs littéraires,
car c’est une chouette petite communauté
qui me suit dans mes fugues,
m’encourage par leurs commentaires
et leurs remerciements.
J’ai répondu à une vingtaine d’interviews
à la télé, à la radio
et dans la presse écrite.
J’ai eu des propositions de partenariats,
fait d’étonnantes rencontres
et eu d’incroyables opportunités.
Une vraie vie de booktubeur débutant.
(Rires)
Et là, je vais dire un truc
qui va plaire aux adultes :
« Ils n’avaient pas tort mes parents.
La réalité, ça vaut le coup. »
(Applaudissements)
Mais j’ajouterai surtout
qu’elle me permet d’explorer
d’autres pans du livre et de la lecture.
Alors ce soir, je vous invite à fuguer
quelques secondes avec moi vous aussi.
Je vais vous lire un extrait du livre
de Pascal Quignard à propos de la musique.
Et pour ça, j’ai besoin du doux bruit
de la pluie.
Est-ce que vous pouvez taper
du doigt contre votre paume
en continu pendant que je lis ?
Voilà, surtout pas en rythme,
comme des gouttes de pluie.
« On dit de certaines pluies
qu’elles martèlent,
d’autres qu’elles tambourinent,
d’autres qu’elles crépitent.
Ces images, indépendamment de
l’impression de vérité qu’elles procurent,
sont à proprement parler extraordinaires :
un tambourin, un feu, un marteau
pour dire la pluie.
De telles images conduisent alors
à inverser la comparaison à leur source. »
(Applaudissements)